Donald Trump did not go to Joe Biden's inauguration
breaking with tradition.
The first president in, I believe, 152 years
not to go to their replacement's inauguration.
Trump left.
He went to Florida early this morning, but
on his way out, he did leave the White House
and take the Marine One helicopter to Andrews
Air Force Base.
And before getting on Air Force One for that
final flight, delivered a five or seven minute
speech and said even more things that make
no sense to a very deflated crowd.
Trump asking to be remembered if things improve
under Biden.
Trump saying if things do get better in the
next few months, it's because of me.
Please remember me.
You're going to see incredible numbers start
coming in.
If everything is sort of left alone, be careful,
very complex, be careful.
But you're going to see some incredible things
happening.
And remember us when you see these things
happening of you would remember us because
I'm looking at I'm looking at elements of
our economy that are set to be a rocket ship.
It's a rocket ship.
Very powerful elements of the economy that
he's looking at, as he says there, how long
overdue is it for this nightmare to be over?
This morning's speech really reminded me of
that Trump still using the term China virus.
Another aspect of how this morning's speech
was almost the same as the campaign speeches
Trump had been giving China virus.
It's a horrible thing that was put onto the
world.
We all know where it came from, but it's a
horrible, horrible thing.
So be very careful.
Be very, very careful.
But we want to pay great love, great love
to all of the people that have suffered, including
families who have suffered so gravely.
And then that's really the first time I've
heard Trump sincere, sort of sincerely mention
the people who have actually suffered from
the virus.
Trump for good measure.
He can't get away from these things again,
claiming the 1918 flu started in 1917.
We don't know why he's been saying this for
a year, but he said it again, put it in a
position like it's never been before, despite
the worst plague to hit since, I guess you'd
say, 1917 over a hundred years ago.
And it is a good bye for now as Donald Trump
pledges to be back and says have a nice life
to the crowd, sort of the sendoff we would
expect from the guy who never really cared
about his supporters as people.
He cared about them only in so far as it was
useful to his political goals.
The things that we've done have been just
incredible.
And I couldn't have done them, done it without
you.
So just a goodbye.
We love you.
We will be back in some form.
And again, I want to just living I want to
thank our vice president, Mike Pence and Karen,
I want to thank Congress because we really
worked well with Congress, at least certain
elements of Congress, but we really did.
We've gotten so much done that nobody thought
would be possible.
What I do want to thank Congress and I want
to thank all of the great people of Washington,
D.C., all of the people that we worked with
to put this miracle together.
So have a good life.
We will see you soon.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
So there it is.
Have a nice life and you hear YMCA cranking
up there, a surreal and bizarre moment.
And with that, Donald Trump is done flying
off into the sunrise, not into the sunset.
It was early this morning, flying off tomorrow.
Lago in Palm Beach, Florida, before Joe Biden's
inauguration, alluding to, we don't know if
it's a twenty, twenty four run, although I
don't expect that.
We don't know if it's alluding to there were
rumors of Trump starting a new party to be
different than the Republican Party.
Rumors of many different things we just don't
know.
But hours before leaving office, Donald Trump
issuing one hundred and forty three pardons.
And I do want to talk about that.